You've got mail.
Goodbye.
To all of you who thought AOL was voiced by a computer,...
...now let's set the record straight.
I recorded those phrases.
Welcome!
You've got mail!
File's done.
Goodbye.
My name is Elwood Edwards and I'm the voice of "You've got mail."
In 1989, my wife was a customer service rep...
...for the company that was about to become America Online.
She heard Steve Case talking to some of the programmers...
...about how fun it would be to add a voice to the software.
I've been an announcer throughout my entire broadcasting career,...
...and she volunteered me.
I scribbled those phrases on a piece of paper...
...and like I say on the cassette deck, I recorded...
...the "Welcome, you've got mail, file's done, goodbye."
It started off as a test just to see if it would catch on,...
...and lo and behold, in the mid-90s, it had really caught on.
And at one point, they said my voice was heard more than 35 million times a day.